- It is time for Drew's news.
If news programs were sensations,
we'd be that feeling you get
when you pull off your panty hose, ah.
With me at the desk, he's got legs
and he knows how to use
'em, Rossi Ross Mathews.
- Hi everybody!
(audience clap)
- Well, first up today
in our news, "Vogue's" May cover girl,
the stunning mom to be,
Rihanna, that's right!
(audience clap)
- [Ross] Oh, look at her.
- When she got pregnant,
Rihanna says that she knew one thing.
She'd never see a maternity aisle
because she loves to dress up.
She talks about the father of the baby,
her partner, ASAP Rocky.
And she says she doesn't let guys out
of the friend zone easy.
And she's known him for a decade,
but everything changed over the pandemic
when they took a road trip, just the two
of them across the country in a tour bus.
Oh God, she's not sure if
she's having a baby shower,
but if she does, it'll
be co-ed with cocktails.
She says she wants
people to leave plastered
and crawling out.
God, she is everything.
- Everything, Rihanna,
there's so much to break down.
One, I wanna go to that
baby shower and get drunk.
Two, interesting that they were friends
and got out of the friend zone.
She doesn't wanna wear maternity clothes.
All I wanna wear is maternity clothes.
That stuff looks so good.
Elastic jeans, sign me up.
- Our next story comes from "The Knot".
That's right, we've got their cover boy
for their summer issue right here,
and it's our very own Ross Mathews.
(audience clap)
- Oh my God.
- [Drew] Let's peak inside.
- Look at that.
Me and my Welly.
- Now, this is obviously Ross
and that is Wellington, Ross' fiance.
And guess who's actually here today?
Welly, hi Welly.
(audience clap)
- Oh, my Welly's here.
- Come join us up on the desk.
- Look at my Welly.
You guys hear me talk
about him all the time.
Here he is.
- Speaking of, ah, Harry Styles is said
to hit the Coachella stage
again this next weekend
because he already nailed
it this past weekend.
"Marie Claire" reports
that Harry brought out a
surprise guest pop icon,
Shania Twain, and they both dressed up
in head to toe sequins.
They sang "Man, I feel like a woman",
which is a great title
'cause it includes everybody.
And Harry revealed that he
listened to so much Shania
with his mom in the car growing up.
He says that Shania
taught him how to sing,
gave him amazing memories with his mom
and also taught him men are trash.
Harry's album coming out
called "Harry's house"
is about to drop,
but his first single has
already broken records
as it got 16 million streams
in its first 24 hours on Spotify.
(audience clap)
- I think I was responsible
for like a million of those.
- We've got a dilemma
that we found on Reddit.
I thought this was actually
really interesting.
This was discussed on Elvis
Duran's morning show who I love.
Hey Elvis, if you're out there.
What do you do if your sister is planning
to name your future nephew,
their child after an actual crime?
One woman wrote that she's feuding
with her sister after criticizing
her name choice of arson.
- Which is a rip off of fire starter.
- Fire starter, yes, hello.
- My kid, Harper goes to school,
but the real names are like Yale, Captain,
real interesting names that I never had.
So those are kind of
just cool and different.
But when it gets into crimes,
I don't love it as much.
- I know my son's name is Poison Pete,
but that's a whole other story.
(Drew laughs)
(upbeat music)